[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen mr james t lane
lift every voice and
sing till earth and heaven
ring
ring with the harmon
knees of
liberty
[Music]
let our rejoicing
rise high as the listening
skies
let it resound
loud as the roar
sea
sing a
song
full of the faith that the dark past has
taught us
singing a
song
full of the hope that the present has
brought
facing the rising
side of a new day
[Music]
begun
let us march on
till victory
is one
there are many black women who deserve
to have their names on military bases
instead of confederate generals like
mary tuvastre mary was an enslaved black
woman with a talent for drawing one day
during the civil war she happened to see
a drawing of the confederacy's plans for
a new warship so she pulled out some
tissue paper from her dress traced the
plans walked to dc and handed them to
the navy's chief admiral and when she
did she changed the course of history
because that wasn't just any ship those
were plans for the first ever ironclad
ship it's the reason why the union navy
dominated the seas and why america's
navy is so revered today but there is no
fort two vestry instead we have fort
beauregard named after confederate
general pierre gustav to tom beauregard
who was a traitor and a losing ass [ __ ]
you know who else should have a base
named after them william cathay
william was a freed slave who wanted to
serve his country so he joined the army
rose through the ranks and ended up
serving with the famous buffalo soldiers
then william fell ill and checked into
an army hospital where it was discovered
that he was actually a woman cathay
williams cathay had disguised herself as
a man so she could fight for her country
something that many black women of that
time period did
cathay should have a base named after
her but instead of fort williams we have
fort pickett named after confederate
general george pickett who fled to
canada after the south lost the war so
he was a coward and a traitor and a
losiness [ __ ]
now
fdr didn't care too much for black
people but he made an exception eleanor
roosevelt's friend mary mcleod bethune
mary could have an audience with fdr at
any time and she convinced him to slide
an amendment into a bill that gave
funding to hbcus when the us was
preparing for war the army didn't have
enough pilots so mary convinced the
first lady to tour hbcus where students
were learning to fly at one stop eleanor
went for a plane ride with a black pilot
and that's what convinced the public
that black men could fly planes which
means mary single-handedly paved the way
for the tuskegee airmen
oh to walk the grounds at camp bethune
but instead we have fort hood
named after confederate general john
bell hood who was a traitor and a
loser-ness [ __ ]
and also extremely ugly look at him
he looks like a melting jake gyllenhaal
next up
ariminta ross ariminter ross was a
famous tour guide until the government
of massachusetts begged her to help the
union in the civil war she led the
expeditionary forces on raids trained
soldiers and had such a profound effect
that the general in charge of south
carolina told his troops to free any
slaves they came across now that made
abraham lincoln furious until slaves
started joining the union army it not
only gave the union an advantage it led
to the emancipation proclamation
aramenta even got a pension but it
wasn't under her birth name it was under
her new name
you're gonna flip
harriet tubman
ah
fort tubman it has a nice ring to it but
instead we have fort benning which
sounds like trash because it is trash
because it's named after confederate
general henry benning who was trash
he said by the time the north shall have
attained the power the black race will
be in a large majority and then we will
have black governors black legislatures
black juries black everything is it to
be supposed that the white race will
stand for that well have a seat [ __ ]
because it's happening
in 1912 two black teenagers were accused
of rape they were tried convicted and
sentenced to death in a single day and
after they were executed a mob of white
men terrorized drove out or killed all
the black people in the surrounding area
and they did that until the entire black
community of oscarville disappeared
the county went from having over one
thousand black residents in 1912 to zero
in 1920. that story is so sad it makes
this story look like a comedy
after the black community had been run
off the white people of forsyth county
said you know what we could use a big
old lake so they made one right where
the town of oscarville had just been
they flooded the area and literally
covered up the entire town with water
this is what it looks like right now
but the town is still under there the
homes and churches and schools they're
still down there and now people go
boating on top of them
compared to that this is truly a rom-com
now you might be thinking what a weird
isolated incident but just like the rat
who ate the pizza in the subway this
story is both crazy and common
ever heard of collegia alabama it was
once a thriving black community with a
black college the first black railroad
and literally hundreds of family homes
today it's lake martin at least they had
the decency to name it after a black
person
and if you think this kind of thing only
happened in the south let me introduce
you to a place called central park it's
named after that coffee shop on friends
central park used to have a black
community in it called york hill
but the city of new york destroyed york
hills so that they could build the
central park reservoir because if
there's one thing new york needs it's
another place for ducks to hang out but
if you come here don't try to feed those
ducks they are very aggressive
mess around and lose a finger now when
the residents of york hill were kicked
out of their homes they fled to another
black community nearby called seneca
village and then a few years later new
york destroyed seneca village too so
that they could build central park on
top of it the craziest part of this
story is that i work a few blocks away
from a place where the government
disappeared to black communities and
until recently i didn't know about any
of it you know why because it worked
they tried to erase black communities
and they came way too close but now
there are people doing the research so
we are finally learning about places
like henry and mckee islands which is
now located under lake guntersville in
alabama and vanport oregon which is now
located under delta park and all of
these towns which are
currently literally underwater
hey wait hold on
what was that last one
old never sink that's a real place
well if we've learned one thing today
it's never assumed something is
unsinkable black people aren't usually
known for being anti-vaccine but a lot
of us are anti-taking the vaccine first
because there is a long history of
doctors experimenting on black people to
figure out ways to help white people for
example many of the practices in modern
day gynecology come from experimenting
on slaves the gynecologist is not fun in
2021 so you know the very first speculum
was bad but even after slavery ended
scientists were taught that black bodies
and minds were inferior and because of
this that their bodies belonged to
science even if it was against their
will now i didn't say they thought black
minds and bodies were inferior i said
they were taught this it was part of
their curriculum it came between how to
turn on a bunsen burner and how to get
stains out of your lab coat
in 1932 the united states public health
service conducted the tuskegee study of
untreated syphilis in the negro male
scientists from the u.s government
decided they wanted to see what happens
to black men when syphilis is left
untreated this is what our government
decided to focus on in 1932. gerald
should we solve the great depression we
could or hear me out we could conduct
this insane experiment
now what human being would just sign up
to let syphilis kill them the answer is
no damn body so they got 600 black men
to participate in that study by lying to
them the men thought they were being
treated and instead the government gave
them fake medicine and just let them die
which may sound unbelievable but take a
look around america today letting people
die is kind of our government's thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]